what up space fam goes in here for anime
uproar and today once again we are gonna
go over the latest insane development in
Demon Slayer
I mean moves on is going absolutely ham
right now so definitely stay tuned for
that
if you like seeing these Demon Slayer
videos on this channel make sure to
smash that like button to let me know if
you haven't be sure to subscribe and
ring that notification bell because if
you don't you will not know when you
would even say your videos come out for
more demon Surtur content and crucial
updates about the upcoming movie and
seasons follow us on twitter and
instagram at anime uproar linked in the
description there will be manga spoilers
in this video we're going to be talking
about the latest chapter after all
chapter 180 you've been warned now
without further ado let's jump into it
the last chapter was really sad and
amazing in its own way but there wasn't
much action it was more about the
aftermath of the fight against upper
moon one kakushi bow we had to say
goodbye to the 14 year old miss Spiller
Mui cheeto and Tucson amis brother ganya
both have been part of the story for a
long time and it was absolutely crazy to
see them go but that's the kind of
series this is all demon Slayers
especially pillars are willingly risking
their lives every day and they're
prepared to die it's part of the job
description and there's the sense that
nobody's really safe no matter how young
they happen to be we start this chapter
called recovery with tan general ng you
hearing about who's died and who hasn't
from a crow taja can't help a break out
in tears when he hears about who's died
he goes from dry eye to Niagara Falls
real quick that's penrose character
though while we are not shown any tears
coming from the stoic GU Tonto falls a
bit behind Gil but he doesn't stop he
accepts that this is reality he drops a
powerful quote here he says to himself
and I quote keep looking forward fight
on until the end just like everyone else
I'll go without hesitation and quote
this is the position that Guillaume a
Ants enemy also found themselves in
during the last chapter
there's no time to mourn they have to go
fight moves on now Guillaume a sign a
meet and you know Andy you are all
approaching moves on so that will truly
be an epic battle when it begins we
learn a bit more about the dance of the
fire-god as well we learned that ponchos
they
the fire-god is in an incomplete state
tundra says he's someone that couldn't
inherit it he saw Central's letter and
understood there's a 13th form of the
dance of the fire-god
but Tundra only knows up to the 12 side
note though I would not be surprised at
tundra ends up learning this later
somehow or even create some new form
since in those case any - and you have
all been able to do the same despite the
fact that the dance of the fire-god is
incomplete Angela tells himself that he
will take out moves on no matter what
for everyone's sake but then we jump to
the headquarters and we're told that
they're too late tell me your son could
not endure anymore and moves on has
revived the big bad boss has been
unleashed and he's out for blood we are
told that the first team is about to
arrive to his location and that the
second team is right behind that kiriya
aoi Isshiki the current head of the
Demon Slayer Corps sends word for them
to stop and wait for the pillars to
arrive he is freaking out so you can bet
something's about to go down then we
jump to the demon seer members who have
found Muslims ball of flesh little do
they know now that it's empty they're
clearly novices and have no idea what to
do they talk about how their swords
can't reach the ball of flesh and wonder
about what they should do as they try to
remain calm a crow tells them to stand
by then one not so bright dude says this
isn't a situation to be waiting we don't
know what will happen before the pillars
arrive and not surprisingly he is the
first to get killed by Musa
Mullen has white hair currently and he's
not wearing any clothes it's like the
seven deadly sins where seemingly
darkness is substituted for clothing
like pants he also has mouths with sharp
teeth all over his body he just goes
crazy killing countless demon Slayers
present these guys are literally useless
against him in fact they're worse than
useless they are actually helping him
recover quicker the title of this
chapter recovery was clearly referring
to moves on recovery we get an entire
full page size panel to show just how
much damage Mullen is inflicting on the
demon slayer core kiria is screaming for
them to wait for the pillars to arrive
and explains that if they don't they
will just be food for Moses recovery
that is exactly what's going on now that
moves on is free he is killing every
living body in the vicinity and they're
all powerless to stop him a crow shouts
for
everyone to fall back but everyone that
was there seems to be dead already
moves on then kills the crow that guy is
ruthless and thorough yeah
moves on says that after living over a
thousand years he's lost the sense to
taste food but now that he was starving
he could truly appreciate how very
delicious it was for the first time in a
long while moves on things that we
ishiki is for deliberately bringing them
food yes kid II have tried to get
everyone to retreat but it was not a
good idea to send them there in the
first place not sure what he expected to
happen even if the pillars were there I
can't see any of these weaker demon
Slayers being very useful in a fight
against moves on to throw salt on the
wound Mullen says that whoever succeeded
Yui Isshiki is outstanding he even
offers to turn Korea into a demon since
he lost most of his subordinates
including his strongest upper moons
Korea tries to make sure that the second
team retreats so that they don't end up
like the first team who just helped
moves on with his recovery then we get
the see moves on and Tamayo Tamayo is
another character we known for a long
time she's helped on zero na Zuko
Shinobu and the entire Demon Slayer core
up to this point even though she's a
demon Musa points out that the turn a
demon into a human medicine that she
used had no effect on him whether this
effect will be delayed or not remains to
be seen despite how many hundreds of
people have tried to kill moves on over
the years none of them have succeeded
Tomeo says she wants her husband and
children back Mouzon says then die right
now and go to the side of the family you
killed this is one of the biggest
tragedies and demon slayer the way tama
yo a good-hearted person was turned into
a demon and ended up not being able to
control herself was so freakin tragic
she killed the most important people in
the world to her her husband and her
children she's had to live with that
guilt all the way up to this point sure
it was Mulan's demon blood that drove
her to do it but I bet that deep down
she feels unbearable guilt about hurting
the people that she loved more than
anything
after all a mother's love for her
children is one of the most powerful
things in this world for a mother losing
her children would be unbearable as is
but in this case Tama yo was also the
one who killed them moves on is truly
among the most
of villains for putting a mother through
that he then proceeds to crush her head
without mercy we jump to you she doe who
loves Tom Mayo more than anything it
seems like he can sense what happened
and he crushes the floor beneath him
with his bare hand we see his face and
he looks like he is ready to brutally
devour mousse on
if only pure rage alone was enough to
beat him however I do hope that he gets
to play a part in Milan's defeat because
he definitely has a compelling reason to
get revenge against the demon king of
pop moves on keeps making his way
through demon slayer teams
it's absolutely brutal he's just
prancing through them as he devours that
many recovers kiria keeps pointlessly
saying for people to get away and stay
back but they cannot hope to outrun the
insanely quick and powerful moves on
we're also told that Gill and by
extension time zero are in the opposite
direction so they're not in a position
to save these people
Kiera is sweating the children keep
dying and moves on has completely
recovered according to Korea Tommy owes
death was meaningless but I wouldn't be
surprised if we later figure out that it
was meaningful perhaps it will be a
delayed effect of the medicine she gave
moves on or something like that
otherwise this truly was worse than
pointless moves on is fully recovered
countless demon Slayers have been
butchered and the insanely talented Tom
AO is dead at the end of the chapter we
get a full page of Mulan looking evil AF
he smiles and seems confident in his
ability to kill everyone without any
help from subordinates he says that he
will eliminate the demon Slayers tonight
he will Massacre them all what a crazy
chapter things went from zero to a
hundred real quick as Drake would say we
went from wolves on being trapped to
Multan massacring countless people I
don't think any chapter had anywhere
close to this many deaths
we are definitely approaching a climax
up to this point the demon Slayers kept
defeating Upper moons and it seemed like
things were really turning in their
favor however after this chapter Mulan
has completely altered that perception
now he seems unstoppable I can't wait to
see what happens in the next chapter let
me know what you thought of this chapter
and where you think we're going from
here if you enjoyed this chapter of you
make sure to smash that like button to
let me know if you haven't be sure to
scribe and ring that notification bell
because if you don't you will not know
when you demon center videos come out
for more Demon Slayer content and
crucial updates about the upcoming movie
and seasons follow us on Twitter and
Instagram at anime uproar a big thank
you goes out to our patrons over on
patreon who help make videos like this
one possible I especially want to thank
our pro here to your patrons the one and
only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason
Wilson Kings ljus angel Cruz Steelers
poet Pablo a triple straight $30 beat
Akagi and Anatoly Cassatt's key DJ
Nathaniel and alpha do and are the one
tier patrons the ones who stay atop all
clans Stephen and Radha a lo'laan
automatic 239 makoto-kun and your boy
Seth
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon calm
and emile for and becoming a patron
today for as little as $1 if you do so
you'll get your name featured in future
videos alongside these amazing people
right here and you'll even get access to
our private patron only discord so check
out patreon commonly
if you're interested you can also now
join the YouTube channel and support
more content that way if you prefer no
matter what way you choose to support us
you'll get the same great benefits
anyways thanks again for everything and
until next time see you space cowboys
[Music]